[Musique]
pour commencer on va faire une petite
gymnastique oculaire je vais vous
demander de fermer les yeux
et de respirer profondément
il fait sombre et froid
peut-être moins 10 un peu moins
certainement
voilà plongée à 25 mètres sous la
surface de la terre
votre vie est suspendue à votre piolet
par la dragonne
au-dessus de vous
il fait sombre et en dessous
le vide
voilà dans les entrailles d'un glacier
et comme seul compagnon
la peur
viscérale tout au fond de vos tripes
celle de mourir
ah non
voici la rage aussi
celle de survivre
heureusement ce jour-là
c'est la rage qui va l'emporter sur la
peur
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
c'était le 23 février 2021 et quelques
jours après j'ai eu besoin de dessiner
au lieu de mettre des mots dessus
me raccrochant à mes passions d'antan
lorsqu'on me disait que ce serait plutôt
mais limite physique qui allait
m'empêcher de faire des choses dans la
vie à ce moment là la montagne était
plutôt loin de moi
alors en sortant de l'hôpital j'ai
commencé par dessiner
voilà ce que ça a donné bon mes talents
de dessinatrice ne sont pas si des rangs
mais comme ça vous avez une image
c'était le 23 février 2021 donc ce
jour-là la montagne était magnifique
nous sommes partis avec un ami à
l'assaut du stralorn un sommet de plus
de 4000 mètres dans les Alpes
valaisannes
en conquérant de l'inutile vous
connaissez la formule nous partions
profitez
de cette belle journée dehors chanceux
c'est certain
qu'elle privilège d'être là seul à
l'assaut d'un sommet
dont on a rêvé très longtemps
nous partions donc 4 heures du matin
depuis la cabane Britannia
nous avons enfilé nos chaussures
et puis mis nos skis de randonnée
le seul bruit
qui couvrait le silence était le
glissement de nos pots de phoques
sur la neige gelée
15 mètres de corps ne séparés mon ami et
moi il y a peu de place pour les
bavardages à ce moment-là c'est sûr
mais les pensées suffisent
et le ciel étoilé aussi
quelle chance d'être là on se répétait
c'est vrai quoi voilà le sommet déjà
où
ouf enfin le sommet peut-être après
quelques heures de course
la vue était magnifique sur les 4000 aux
alentours et sur le serveur
mais à ce moment-là la courte accolade
ne nous fait pas oublier qu'il reste la
descente la partie certainement la plus
difficile dans une course d'alpinisme
ce qui en pratique doivent le savoir
parce que la descente ça veut dire la
fatigue et puis on est aussi un peu
moins lucide
un peu moins conscient des risques il
faut faire attention on le sait
on passe les difficultés sans souci
et nous voyons le col de l'Adler au loin
la-bas nous savons que nous allons
rejoindre le glacier de la laine et puis
alors il n'y aura plus qu'à se laisser
glisser jusqu'à la cabane
et nous aurons mérité la bonne bière au
refuge c'est certain comme à chaque fois
j'étais devant crampon au pied
des skis sur le dos mon ami était
derrière
et c'était le seul moment où nous
n'avions pas la corde décidé à la
remettre à vendre rejoindre le glacier
je me retourne
Bernard
le glacier englouti
je dégringole une chute vertigineuse
j'ai l'impression que je vais jamais
m'arrêter
je pense que je vais mourir
je sais que je vais mourir et puis non
finalement je reste suspendu à ce pioler
vous souvenez par la dragonne
il me retient et je m'y accroche comment
s'accroche à la vie
à ce moment-là je suis étonné d'être en
vie c'est sûr je regarde en haut je ne
vois plus le bleu du ciel voilà de monde
celui des vivants et puis cette antre de
glace qui m'a englouti
en dessous de moi le vide
je ne dois pas tomber plus bas
le temps s'arrête et je me surprends
à regarder ces beautés glacées la nature
est un architecte c'est magnifique des
couleurs différentes des ponts de neige
bon c'est pas le moment de faire des
photos pour Instagram et puis de toute
façon j'ai pas accès à mon téléphone mon
sac lui il doit être quelque part en bas
et puis et puis il faut survivre d'abord
jure
je veux pas mourir là
celui qui est lié au pragmatisme
il est fort celui-là toujours là au bon
moment enfin souvent heureusement et
puis
je me dis qu'il faut attendre c'est la
seule chose à faire attendre attendre
que les secours arrivent je suis
moi-même formé en montagne je sais que
la condition sinequanone c'est que mon
ami aille bien qu'il ait pu rejoindre le
col qu'il a appelé les secours et puis
ils vont venir me chercher
alors j'attends blessé à la jambe en
état d'hypothermie
le ennemi la plus longue de ma vie je
crois
tout à coup sur ma doudoune détrempé un
peu de neige
il n'y a pas de vent ce jour-là c'est
les secours c'est certain
alors je me penche très fort en arrière
pour voir un interstice de ciel bleu et
là j'entends
on va venir vous chercher mais pas tout
de suite
la demi-heure la plus longue de ma vie
encore plus long que leur ennemi d'avant
bon et puis là l'instinct de survie
il se dit mais encore là c'est bon non
il y a les secours là je prise mais non
j'attends je sais faire
le guide de montagne descend à ma
hauteur
ça va aller il me dit ça en suisse
allemand mais je voulais vite
et là
King
il a clipé le mousqueton sur mon
baudrier
et nous voilà tous les deux troyés par
un câble métallique à rejoindre la
surface de la Terre et les vivants je
m'effondre au bord du trou béant lui
adresse à peine un regard tu as osé ma
vallée
peut-être parce que ma température
corporelle est à 32 degrés c'est peu
c'est la période peut-être que vous
savez quand on arrête de trembler et
qu'on commence à être très fatigué
on me dit que peut-être j'aurai des
séquelles bon
vu l'état de mon cerveau
je me dis que c'est pas grave
alors on m'embarque à l'hôpital moi la
seule chose que je veux savoir c'est mon
ami il va comment il va bien il va bien
il est à Zermatt c'est un autre
hélicoptère qui l'a amené là-bas
je respire à nouveau
puis le séjour à l'hôpital sera
expéditif je fais des blagues à tout va
on me renvoie vite
pas étonnant on me recoucou la jambe
c'est un peu moche mais bon je tremble
donc ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
me voilà reparti chez moi bequille au
bras clopinclopant
les habits déchirés
un peu fatigué certes j'ai des
courbatures à l'épaule c'est bizarre
mon piolet est toujours là on me l'a
ramenait toutes mes affaires aussi super
je vais pouvoir repartir en montagne la
semaine prochaine
puis je rentre mon ami lui
quand il me récupère à l'hôpital
alors regard vide
c'est comme si lui avait enduré
l'accident de manière beaucoup plus
personnelle c'est vrai quoi il m'a vu
disparaître mourir peut-être et puis je
suis là à nouveau c'est bizarre
mais bon on rentre puis la vie continue
quoi
nouveau boulot peine de cœur
déménagement
la vie continue quoi je parle de tout ça
à mes proches je leur raconte que ce
jour-là j'avais des bonnes étoiles les
étoiles des
mais suis seulement du coup ça compte à
moitié
j'avais des sacrés bonnes étoiles alors
j'en parle d'un air tout à fait détaché
c'est pas ma mère qui dira le contraire
et puis les récits d'alpinistes amateurs
ou de montagnards comme nous voulons
sont assez fascinant n'est-ce pas
il y a ce côté un peu
buzz ça fait souvent la une des journaux
d'ailleurs
puis c'est pas tous les jours que
quelqu'un tombe dans une crevasse et en
ressort vivant c'est clair donc bon je
raconte mon histoire et puis la
curiosité c'est un c'est comme tout et
la vie continue
plusieurs mois plus tard
je me rends compte qu'en fait le glacier
il a avalé une partie de mon âme en tout
cas de mon énergie vitale ça c'est sûr
je ressens plus rien je suis vide
déchiré en petits morceaux en fait
je comprendrais que bien plus tard que
c'est ce qu'on appelle le post
traumatisme
que
parfois c'est un peu dur à gérer
alors j'ai osé le dire à personne
il m'a fallu me rendre compte que je me
sentais comme le pantalon que je portais
ce jour-là
déchiré en lambeau
et pourtant cette vieille relique je
voulais pas l'acheter à la poubelle
c'est la même chose avec ce que je
ressentais
de la tristesse profonde de la
mélancolie un peu aussi
et puis il a fallu du temps encore du
temps pour que je puisse refaire ma
trace trace nouvelle en montagne j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps j'allais plus
sur les glaciers j'allais beaucoup toute
seule j'arrivais plus à supporter les
autres et leur regard leur injonction à
être heureuse mais ta sérieux
tu as survécu c'est magnifique
croque la vie à plein dedans encore plus
qu'avant mais moi j'arrivais pas
il m'a fallu comprendre que souvent les
limites
elles sont pas physiques en fait elles
sont plutôt intérieures
surtout en montagne en montagne on n'ose
pas dire qu'on a peur
on n'ose pas avouer nos faiblesses
pourtant elles sont là on en a tous et
toutes c'est normal mais en montagne ce
milieu qui
[Musique]
elle m'accumuler le déplus les
kilomètres les comme sur Strava etc etc
il y a peu de place pour les échecs
et pour avouer qu'on a peur
en fait c'est ça qu'il a fallu
que je prenne conscience que mes peurs
qui étaient là j'avais le droit de les
ressentir
j'avais le droit de les partager aussi
même avec mes compagnons de cordée
parce que vous savez
dans le monde de la montagne et je suis
sûr qu'il y en a parmi vous qui font de
la montagne j'ai vu les t-shirts et puis
bon on est en Gruyère
on n'a pas trop le choix
quand on est en montagne surtout quand
on est une fille on n'ose pas trop dire
qu'on a peur pourtant ce jour-là le 23
février 2021 j'aurais dû dire à mon avis
à mon ami que j'allais pas bien
on aurait dû faire demi-tour
bon avec des filles on pourrait refaire
le monde pas vrai
puis quand je me suis rendu compte de ça
je me suis dit qu'il fallait un sacré
travail pour que mes peurs deviennent
mes compagnons mais nouveaux compagnons
de cordée
et que j'arrête de les prendre
comme des ennemis en fait
on nous dit souvent il faut dépasser ses
limites aller contre ses peurs les
mettre de côté
mais non je crois pas
je crois qu'on peut les prendre avec
bienveillance
on peut faire en sorte que ce soit elle
qui fixe nos limites mentales et
physiques
on a le droit de les ressentir de les
partager
de les exprimer
et quand je me suis rendu compte de ça
ça a été une libération immense
j'ai pu retourner en montagne avec les
copains les copines
et puis maintenant quand j'ai peur je le
dis
alors je dis pas
mais ça ressemble un peu à ça quand même
alors
je vais pas vous demander de tomber dans
une crevasse pour vous rendre compte de
ça c'est pas très agréable mais par
contre je crois qu'on peut tous se poser
un moment dans un coin de nature ou
ailleurs là où vous vous sentez bien en
fait puis réfléchir à tout ça
se dire que la course
au dépassement des limites
à ses propres limites
et que
nos limites là-dedans c'est celle-ci
qu'il faut respecter
celle qui viennent du fond de notre trip
car c'est elle qui nous permette
d'avancer tranquillement dans la vie
sans avoir trop peur
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]